President Trump and congressional
leaders reached a landmark budget deal
avoiding the threat of a historic debt
default the agreement does not address
America's rising debt instead it
increases spending by hundreds of
billions of dollars we Jiang is at the
white house for us so we the president
promised to pay off the debt in eight
years have the lawmakers and the
president given up on dealing with the
debt well it seems like for now that is
on hold the parties don't agree on much
these days but federal spending is
touchy for everybody here because
everyone likes to talk about keeping it
in check but nobody wants to cut
valuable programs and what we are seeing
is all of them coming together in true
Washington fashion to borrow more money
and kick the can down the road this deal
allows the government to do that until
after the 2020 election it suspends the
debt ceiling and boost spending by 320
billion dollars increasing overall
government spending to one point three
seven trillion dollars next year
Republicans are happy to steal in big
military increases while Democrats can
protect domestic programs President
Trump announced the deal on Twitter
saying there were no poison pills
implying that the deal had nothing in it
he was opposed to since Democrats have
agreed not to attach controversial
policy measures to future spending bills
but deficit hawks say the u.s. debt
around 22 trillion dollars is a real
concern arguing future generations will
pay the price now the president
Republicans and Democrats have all
railed against the debt in the past but
gala
no longer seems to be a major issue for
anyone at least for now all right we to
Jane reporting from Washington thank you